[Musique]
surtout ne me prenez pas pour une
imbécile parce qu'on m'a surnommé
bcassine si je prends l'air plus bête
que je le suis vraiment c'est pour
amuser les petits enfants et si je vous
amuse avec mes gros sabots pour moi il
n'y a rien de plus beau car des gens
importants j'en connais croyez-moi
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus bêes que mesir
ils ont des ch pour vivre monagne ils
ont des chaporons vivent les Bretons ils
ont des chaporons vivent la Bretagne ils
ont des chapons vivre les Bretons
surtout ne me prenez pas pour une béc je
me suis regardé dans la glace et si je
vous fais rire ça prouve que les Bretons
ont de L'Hour en toute
occasion tous les côtés des jolis savons
pour nous il n a rien de plus beau de
marcher avec toi dans les pr les vois
c'est une vie rêvée pour les JO ils ont
des chapons vivre la Bretagne ils ont
des chapons vivre les Bretons ils ont
des chapons vivent la Bretagne ils ont
des chaporons vivre les pretons surtout
ne me prenez pas pour une imbécile parce
qu'on m'a surnommé Bécassine si je fais
des bêtises sans jamais m'arrêter tout
au long des bandes de dessiné c'est pour
faireir un peu les grands et les petits
avec mes saveau mon parapluies si tu ne
me crois pas et bien puis pour toi
j'irai en parler avec mes oies ils ont
des ch vivre la bretag ils ont dé
pourons vire les Brons ils ont chons
vire la Bretagne ils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]